it is my great pleasure to invite our
distinguished panelists to join me on
stage for this very exciting session the
operator CEO session discussing
wholesaling fiber as a driver of
business success so let me ask Sean
Atkinson CEO of Cyro Elisabetta RIBA CEO
of open fiber over on CEO of Talia's
Canova Mike max-eye chairman of open
reach and last but not least Greg mesh
the CEO of Citi fiber to join me here on
stage I think one important thing that
is common in all of the operators who
are present with their business leaders
here today is that they're all having a
very important whole set as this when it
comes to fiber even though their
backgrounds and business models might be
different we will start with the opening
statements of our CEOs here and I would
like to first invite Shaun to actually
deliver his opening statement with a few
slides Thank You Joseph afternoon
everybody
and it's great to be here we'll try and
as I say get you out of the post-launch
law so I'm here to just kind of very
briefly introduce you to Cyril sorrows a
new entrant into the Irish market and
you heard maybe before lunch if you were
here Ireland's just made it into the
panorama for fiber-to-the-home something
where we're delighted that we're getting
there but in early days and a lot more
work to do
so just a bit of background about
Ireland and that just to sort of set the
scene if you think about the telecoms
Ireland is a very low population density
so there's a lot of four and a half
million people but spread across a large
area so in terms of the density there in
population rolling of fibre it's a
challenging America we don't have a lot
of high-rise empty use and you know so
it's a particularly challenging market
but I suppose the feature of the market
over the last number
and before Soria was it was sort of born
was particularly low investment the
incumbent operator had been through a
lot of sort of financial difficulties
post privatisation so they've been so
it's a significant under investment in
this sector that resulted in I say
Ireland lagging behind in the broadband
stakes and you can see the some of the
statistics there and this is where we
are today that we even you know thirty
percent of fixed broadband connections
are less than 30 megabits per second and
that's today the economy in Ireland is a
small open economy and part of the EU
obviously the digital economy is very
important at six percent projected to
grow up to ten percent but even within
that though the challenges are you know
the SMEs which is obviously critical to
sort of job creation so particularly
outside of the cities which is part of
what SOI Roosevelt you know 80 percent
can't process online payments you know
the broadband is hasn't sort of reached
out of the Digital Agenda hasn't really
reached out into the outside of the
cities so why Cyril right so sorry is
was created was launched in 2015 and
it's a joint venture 50 percent owned by
the electricity company and the national
utility come to ESB and by Vodafone and
we're the first nationwide rollout of
fibre to the home in Ireland we were
phase one targets which is to get to 25
percent of the homes we should have four
million homes and we don't have across
50 towns as you can see them there in
the map spread spread across Ireland
focusing primarily outside the major
cities where there is competition
between the incumbent and between the
cable operator in the markets but the
regional towns in Ireland were
particularly poorly served by broadband
and that was the opportunity that Cyril
saw and what we are is were an open
access network provider so just a bit of
back to I think everybody in the room
and all about Vodafone but you can see
obviously it's now investing in fixed
networks across the 17 markets as well
as what it's doing in the mobile sector
but why ESP this was a ESP idea
initially and as utility company they
looked and said obviously is utility
company with a connection to every home
in Ireland there is a need for broadband
in Ireland and can we do something can
we actually put fiber-optic network onto
the overhead lines
and into the ducts and then use those
and pathways to get the last mile and
the access fiber network built and that
was what sort of bought with Sawyer was
born out of was that vision by ESP to
say can we actually solve this problem
and can we make a good commercial return
on it is it a good business model and
actually do something in terms of social
responsibility and it's a betterment of
Ireland and this is how we do it it's no
real secret in here obviously if you
look at the the top everybody be
familiar with what the network looks
like um in terms of at the core network
it reasonably well served but the last
mile so sorry or what we do is rather
than digging in everywhere put the fiber
in the ground we try and use the
existing infrastructure so we get down
to the local exchange we started a
substation and we follow the pathways
into the homes using the street
furniture and the overhead and
underground networks as they are so
that's probably really the you know the
innovative and we'll hear some more
later on about that the innovative
feature of sorrow is to drive that and
build that out over the electrical
network so really I dropped a conclusion
there so sorry I'll just put it in your
mind as to what it is where Ireland's
first 100 percent fibre to the home
network with a wholesale business model
we're an open access non-discriminatory
provider so we have I think knowing
retailers on our network at this stage
varying in sizes from a couple of the
larger retailers you'd be familiar with
down to two local providers as I say
it's an innovative model and we're
really transforming Ireland's telecoms
landscape and I think you know we've
probably changed the conversation even
since sorrow and was conceived of if
there is anyone out there familiar with
the the Irish market it's for others to
move you know we've now as I say we've
you know we've got the regulator that
now has fibre to the home as a category
and his quarterly reports previously
when sorry I was born there was only an
older category which captured everything
else so fibre to the home didn't have
its own category that's now reversed and
you know we were delighted today that
you know fibre to the home is now on the
panorama here with it
the council and it's very much around
that sort of ever see future-proofing
and everybody's familiar with the you
know the the the vision that was painted
here over the last couple of days of
ubiquitous fiber network and in sorrow
we're very much working towards that in
Ireland so thank you very much thank you
very much Sean next up I would like to
invite at least a better reaper to make
her opening statement as you've all seen
today morning open fiber has won the
operator ftth award for 2018 so we're
all very curious to hear your story yes
thank you and I'm really proud for the
award also because we are a young
company born last year one years ago and
after one years we achieved such
important results that we are very keen
and proud to share with you but I'm even
more proud and interest to share with
you the business model that open fiber
select the wholesale only business model
and why we have selected this approach
with reference to a country that still
is not benefiting from the fully
deployment of broadband and his lucky is
well behind when compared in terms of
broadband penetration with European
average so we told there was room for
improvement in our country we thought
there was the room for having a new
approach to the development of this
important technology I heard this
morning that we all share the fact that
we need the ftth we need a huge capacity
and speed in order to allow an enable
the digital revolution and we think that
the economics of the FTTH consists
basically in a large fixed and some cost
and passing home
with definitely a comparatively low cost
when you have to add and marginal
customers and when you have to connect
other home at your infrastructure so the
most cost-effective answer to this
business we think is the wholesale model
that allow us basically to reap the
economics of scale that the business
needs but also to share with many
operators the burden of the investment
that is requiring to the other son I
mean we are in a very good position
because Overland Fiber has no legacy
network so we can address this point
without any kinds of conflict of
interest and we are can facilitate the
development of telco operators but also
the entrance of new players in the telco
space that exactly the main purpose of
our open platform that is delivering not
only passive infrastructure and passive
network but also active solution in
order to accommodate the development of
new players in the telco space after one
year as I mentioned we reach basically
2.5 million home connected so quite an
important numbers if compared with the
numbers of months that we had in terms
of rollout we leverage of course on the
network that we receive from the
acquisition of Metro web we are now
covering 13 cities in our country and we
are hosting after less than 6 months of
opening at commercial activities 250,000
customers so as small numbers in
comparison with the unique numbers of of
course at the convent's of detail
co-operators but I think it's good start
in order to demonstrate that there is
the room and the opportunity for growing
with this model in our country but also
in the european space why we think that
is interested in this model because we
have to roll out basically in the next
five years and network to provide
services to more than nine point three
millions households and in order to do
that we have to invest something around
three point nine billion euros and this
is going to be dedicated to the coverage
of more or less two hundred and seventy
cities large cities when there is where
there is room for competition but we
don't want to limit this kind of roll
out only to the competitive areas
because we think that italy deserved
newly and future Pru infrastructure also
to reduce the digital divide that
historically has been a big issue for
our country in terms of difficulty in
deployment productivity difficult in
bridging the gap with the Digital Agenda
difficult also increase let's say our
ability to attract also with Turismo or
without any kinds of economical
activities investments in in our space
so we want to ability and facilitate the
deployment also in the areas where there
is no sustainability for a private
operator and in order to do that we have
participated to a specific ocean auction
that has been launched by the public
sector in order to build and manage for
20 years and infrastructure focus on the
so-called the failures market failures
area we want to of these standards and
we are in the progress of starting the
rollout of 9.6 millions of whom
connected receiving in order to pursue
perform this task roughly 1.5 billion
euros of public contribution so we are
going to share the investment we have a
really ambitious plan but we think that
this is going to be feasible using as
much as possible or reusing a must as
much as possible the infrastructure and
pretty much similar to the model that we
are just before my talk we are going to
leverage on the infrastructure of all
the utilities that we will find in the
areas where we are going to deploy the
network but mostly we are going to
leverage on the power power electrical
lines thanks to the fact that we can
have some synergies with our
shareholders and that is the power
incumbent in our country so we'll speed
after rollout thanks to that we will use
all the infrastructure that will find in
order to achieve that and we will go
very quickly in terms of rollout in the
metropolitan areas in order to let me
say fill the gaps of coverage and fill
the gap of opportunities that we think
is there in the market after one year of
existence of open fiber the first result
was really evidence in terms of market
growth
Italy fixed line business as a performer
that definitely a declining trend for
more than 10 years and in 2017 for the
first time this trend reverted with an
increase of 1.5 percent still a small
number but an inversion of the direction
and I think that was the results of the
existence of open fiber in the market
and we think there is still room for
improvement considering that again we
are a mobile only market where more than
33% of our outsoles are mobile only
players more by only customers but not
because they are this
riding to be a mobile only customers but
because there is no alternatives because
the quality that are receiving in
broadband is very poor so moving back to
the the issue or the topics of this
section is an old sale only model a
successful approach I think is the case
also because investors are looking at
this model very very positively and it's
because probably is similar to the ones
of the utilities that they know very
well but also because this model is
reducing the volatility that vertical
integration operators traditionally have
in a competitive environment so to recap
and go into the point and then discuss
we are more than open to discuss our
approach we think that this model is
good for the market and is good for the
industry because it's the only one that
is able to allow economy of scale it's
the only one that could attract
financial investments in the dimension
and in the sites that we need in order
to develop Network and it's also the
only one that will allow competition not
on connectivity that by the way we have
to say it's now a commodity but will
allow competition on services and this
is going to be beneficial for the market
and for the industry and we also think
that through this model we can build an
infrastructure and a platform that will
not be very important for only for
broadband but also for the future of
evolution in the mobile arena such as
the 5g so to recap I think that the
results we achieve after one years are
very important we have to grow we have
to demonstrate that this model could be
viable but I would say that for the ones
that are stating
this is not possible the first evidence
that we deliver to the market are quite
clear in the sense of a confirmation
that this model could work thank you for
the attention
[Applause]
thank you very much hello as a better I
would like to invite over on the CEO of
Tania's Canova to do his opening
presentation coming from a quite
different background rather than
originally separate in that work for ten
years which is now being reintegrated so
that's a quite interesting story to tell
yeah I hope so I will first give you
some background on these Swedish markets
we have for at least the last ten years
done a lot of digitization on the
infrastructure telecom infrastructure in
Sweden and it's strongly correlated to
the data station or the society you can
see this in different rankings doesn't
matter it's a network readiness ranking
or society readiness ranking we are two
top levels in Europe or in the world I
think that's very good and it's very
good for the competitiveness of the
country in Sweden we need to be very
strong in this and Italian portal we
have been a strong part of that data's
ation and we have around 37% to the
household since feed them that has
access to fiber from us and then we have
around 200 more fiber network providers
you will see that later in slides and
you shouldn't forget the mobile port in
our mobile networking speed then we have
99.99 percent 4G coverage for the
population I think that's very very high
still we have complaints every week
since customer demands that you should
be 100% that 99.99 percent is not good
enough so they have extremely strong
demand from the customers to be
connected all the time if it's mobile or
Wi-Fi or fiber they don't care they need
to be connected all the time
and what are the success factors for
this digitalization in sweden it's a
strong demand for high-speed broadband
as has told you we have some different
things in Sweden that is the willingness
to pay for it also if we build fiber
network ftth the customer pays between
2000 and 2500 euros and they gladly paid
that because they were strong demand for
not only broadband the speed and quality
they want to have fiber because fiber is
future-proof and they can relax because
the the house the home is future-proof
we have around 60 to 70% uptake the
first sales campaign and nowadays on
that price level on a connection fee one
reason for that is that a Swedish
population had changed the behavior all
the media consumption almost have been
being changed into the fiber network or
the mobile network that means regular
the line broadcasting TV time shifted TV
video and more Netflix whatever is to
the network so people actually change
the behavior a lot the other one is that
the political will we have a government
a very strong ambition here and the
target is very high in 95% of the
households would have 100 megabit 2020
today's figures is between 75 and 80
percent today 2025 the state that 98%
should have one gigabit service and the
support is also that they will help out
in extremely expensive areas we will get
some subsidies we order provided a fee
bill the network will have some
subsidies from the government
all from the local municipality that
helps out the business case a lot
secondly we have a very strong and I
mean healthy competition as I said we
have like 200 fiber providers mainly
seat 2 networks that I spend at least 4
billion euros the last 20 years to build
our fiber network since the customer
would like to have fiber not only the
speed of 100 megabit 1 gigabit they were
not high fiber and they're willing to
pay for it of course is a strong
competition to be the first player to
build fiber it's new no point getting
there as a second provider so we have
been forced in health away to really
speed up and deploy fiber all over the
place
and then we had a copper migration we
have now started 10 years ago almost in
the ruler area in Sweden closing down
the copper network so far we have
migrated 50,000 customers but on the
rural side mainly to the mobile network
in some cases of course fiber but but
mainly mobile network and these 50,000
customers that represents 2,000 central
offices so we are so far closed down
2,000 central offices we are taking
decision another 1,000 central offices
the next coming years and that's public
on our webpage in the beginning was a
strong debate if we were allowed could
we do that what would happen with the
customers but now both the customers in
media politicians the government support
it's because it drive digitalization of
the society and then back to what you
said about the separation when we
started many years ago we had no
separation the network organization with
Intel there was one unit on the passive
layer and on the active layer and then
2008 we look at open reach and didn't
open reach look alike and any also had
is equal access board and everything and
the reason because we did that was that
we had a very
bad situation a market they were no
trust regarding that and we had lot of
conflicts and arguments and in court all
the time between a regulator asked and
other operators Sui said voluntarily we
will do with legal separation or the
passive Network only copper and fiber
network and and we will sell the same
kind of products internally and
externally and we did that in a good
success we did a lot on M&A s we bought
other network providers and small city
networks and other companies closed to
the to the network layer and they were
not really divided into passive and
active layer so they were in a blend of
all this so we had a situation we have a
very fragmented situation internally a
lot of companies and lot of
organizations a lot of internal issues
so we decided and that we have to clean
up this mess internally so we are now
this year firstly on our formed a new
unit that we called Helia infra that
integrates back disk an OVA company so
in for a new unit actually handles both
the passive layer and active layer that
the total fixed Network mobile network
and cables and all the sites in Sweden
we still have the ambition of course to
sell the same products to the other
operators not because we are forced to
but we would like to do that because it
improves our payback times of course so
we are we have told the regulator that
we will continue as before but in
another internal structure and that new
unit the infra unit I'm heading that one
from now you also have to understand the
speed is three layer model we have at
the bottom we have the infrastructure
layer used to be scan over the cables
copper and fiber layers and then we have
also what we call communication operator
that puts the active equipment in place
and brings a portal to the customer so
they can choose the service provider and
if not satisfied they can choose another
service writer but still had the same
access the fiber axis and on top of that
different service provider of course so
our service pride Italia actually sell
services on top of our communication
operators and on top of other
communication operators and our
communication operator like CTS also
operates on other fiber networks so it
more like a complex model with
everything is open and strong
competition and all layers so if you
look at the market share we have
different levels of mercury and
different levels and they are a little
bit unique because if you look at the
bottom layer
it's very capital-intensive you have to
have certain KPIs and business decision
regarding that layer if your source
provider is a whole another issue how
you calculate your business cases we are
trying to separate the model in
different layers instead right I think
that was lost
slide wonderful thank you very much
[Applause]
next it is my great pleasure to ask Mike
Makai chairman of open reach to deliver
his opening statement thank you very
much
when I was thinking about what I would
say and the theme of the the panel here
I thought it would be useful to talk a
little bit about open reach and yet
under the surface a little bit as to why
it was created in the first place and
how it plays a role in the UK market
open reach everybody knows was created
in 2006 it is the incumbent access
network provider in the United Kingdom
but to understand why it was created in
2006 I think you need to go back a
little bit in time and understand the
the public and regulatory policy that
has operated in the United Kingdom for
in my mind something like the last 30 to
40 years and that is this that the the
public policy of successive governments
regulatory policy of successive
regulators in the UK within the telecoms
market has been the presumption the
competition retail infrastructure etc is
likely to deliver the best outcomes for
the citizens and consumers of VI Kingdom
and that very position as opposed to
other utilities other sectors has I
think informed the way in which the
market structure has involved in the
United Kingdom I could if I wanted to go
back to the original Wireless licenses
that were later in the 80s in the UK and
talk about the structure of those I
could talk about the way in which the
the regional cable licences were later
in the 80s and 90s all of those were
about creating some level of market
competition in the UK and challenging
the incumbent C of whoever was there at
the time and it was most likely BT if
you just even fast-forward the last 20
years we had the local loop unbundling
that took place in the UK the whole idea
there was to provide infrastructure
based competition by opening up the old
BT exchanges and making them accessible
to other alternative operators I was one
myself at the time a cable and was such
that they could offer you know
differentiated broadband services to to
their customers both business and and
retail if you fast forward to 2003 we
had the creation of Ofcom of which I was
a board member for eight very proud
years and I've come continued with the
similar approach of of infrastructure
based competition being at the heart of
its its policy formulation if in its
first market review of the telecoms
market which took place you know between
then and 2006 it concluded that whilst
progress had been made it needed to see
more competition at the retail level
particularly in the UK that led to
the formation of Openreach it was a
regulatory intervention that basically
said we'd like to see retail level
competition we'd like to see the concept
of equivalents introduced with products
and services at a wholesale level being
available to anybody who wanted to then
resell those products to whatever group
of customers they saw as their target
market that model worked well for some
time and then in the recent past which
is why I'm standing here in front of you
there was a new agreement reached
between off carmen and an open reach and
bt that gave further independence to
open reach and that's basically why i'm
here we created a independent company
it's incorporated we have our own
independent board of directors majority
of independence we're now responsible
for setting the strategy the day-to-day
management etc of of open reach itself
and we think very much of bt in two
distinct ways we think of bt very much
as a shareholder which we need to
respect and we also think of the lines
of business within bt ask customers in
the same way as we think of all of our
other 590 customers that we have today
that's a big change we've implemented
that this year more recent
manifestations of that change are the
very fact that I'm standing here in our
bt person I think this is now the second
or third occasion that the open reach
has been is representing itself in
public forums like this and indeed is
making responses to regulatory
consultations and then more recently
you've seen our announcement on the
deployment of FTTP as we call it fibre
to the home where we have announced that
we will be building out 3 million total
homes passed between now and
two-twenty building upon where we are
today those programs or that particular
program was the outcome of the open
reach board and the consultation that it
conducted last year starting last July
and led to us going to the shareholder
to BT to get board approved for that a
couple of weeks ago and then we got
their approval and announced it so one
of the things I'm saying here in the UK
market at least I think you know open
reach was the first scale wholesaler
open which was created because of public
policy and regulatory intervention it
would not have been created that way and
I think that regulatory intervention has
delivered tremendous outcomes for the UK
so open reach we've you know this year
alone will invest about one and a half
billion of capex into into our market we
have cumulatively spent 11 plus billion
in the last ten years we have increased
the rate of capex for the coming years
as we build out the fibre network we
have delivered I think pretty good
outcomes for the UK if you look at the
you know the the coverage that exists
total homes and premises passed it's now
up at 95% for superfast
if you look at the penetrations that we
have 44 percent of that 95 percent you
know buy and take that product and if
you look at the price so I would love to
have the economics of my Swedish
colleague here if you look at the price
at which the consumers pay in the UK
it's extraordinarily competitive and
right up there with the best in the
marketplace so from my point of view I
think those interventions successively
over a twenty thirty year period have
proven the case that the competition
does work that creating a wholesale
market does and can work and that you
need to have regular oversight of how
that market functions to ensure that it
continues to provide the outcomes that
you need it to provide so it is at least
in the UK the wholesale market I think
is contingent upon the right public
policy
the right regulatory policy and then the
right structures in the industry itself
and I think that Openreach is is very
very much living up to that I close with
what our priorities are and then we can
listen to hear from Greg and then get
into the discussion itself but
priorities we have really are twofold as
the incumbent I said earlier and took
some pride in the fact that we have 95%
superfast coverage in the UK at the
moment which around 87% is provided by
open reach okay that's great but what
about the other 5% so we're very focused
on trying to figure out ways to deal
with that residue of the UK population
that does not have access to a decent
broadband I'm pleased to say that the
programs that government and and others
have put in place things like BT UK
things like apt are 100 in Scotland we
expect that number to have as a result
of those programs in the coming two to
three years but that will still leave in
my mind half a million homes in the UK
that we have to do something about and
yes the government has introduced you
know a a backstop statutory uso
on-demand product but I know that's
going to take two or three years to
implement and it's going to be somewhat
unsatisfactory during that period and
afterwards for those poor consumers that
don't have access to it so we have to
find solution to that and we and I think
that's an industry issue and I think
well I can speak for ourselves we've
engaged with with the regulator and with
government on how we might solve that a
second priority is to make the flip to
fibre so that's probably why I'm invited
here we don't appear on your charts or
anything like that we have very very
very low fiber penetration in the UK at
the moment that's full fibre we've made
the trick was in the announcement that
we made it's more in the announcement
than the numbers themselves so you know
fibre first is absolutely the way now
Openreach is thinking about the world so
in any it is a presumption in our minds
that we will fibre first
I think that's a really important things
for people to take away and if we only
if we can't for whatever reason will we
fall back onto onto the copper estate we
still have to manage the copper estate
because we don't have the benefit or
privilege of not having that and it's
still providing fantastic service and
decent broadband speeds to the vast
majority of the United Kingdom but we
have crossed that Rubicon we have
decided we're going to make the
investment we're going to compete just
like the markets have been structured in
the past and we're going to deploy fiber
as quickly as we can and I think you
know the program itself is to get up to
about a million million-plus homes or
premises pass per year those are our two
priorities we mustn't lose sight of
either we can't have have-nots and then
gigabit speeds over here we have to deal
with the have-nots and we have to as
industry stand up to that and then face
into it but at the same time
we also have to make the investment that
we think is necessary to keep the UK the
leading economy in the g20 from a
digital point of view
those are my opening remarks I look
forward to the debate thank you very
much indeed
[Applause]
thank you very much Mike and Greg and
last but not least it's my great
pleasure to Mike Greg mash this year of
City Fiber the very newest member of the
FTTH Council Europe to join us on stage
and deliver his opening thank you and
and by the way first of all thank you
and the ftth council because I've been a
huge follower and have been coming to
him for years and years and years
I mean city Fiber a lot don't realize we
are over seven years old we've been
working at this for a long time it did
it didn't just come about and before I
go on to that slide it's going into
automatic mode I stopped that must
that's how fast we go that's part of one
of one of our whole things is speed
speed is a weapon you could see what the
problem is
however before I go into that I do want
to thank everybody out here for taking
your Valentine's Day away and I do want
a picture of this so I can send to my
wife to show that I'm with a whole bunch
of old white males there is no diversity
in this industry yet and having young
daughters I need to change that
anyway City Fiber is publicly traded we
are on the London Stock Exchange we are
seven years old we're open access hotel
provider we are a catalyst for change we
believe we're the spark we believe that
the open reach announcement two weeks
ago was a result of us we believe that
the announcement from talk talked about
wanting to do fiber was a result of us
we do believe that it's the Challenger
it's the noon it's the it's the the
group that challenges the status quo
that makes the change and we believe
we're that agent in the UK and we've
been doing it for quite a while we have
done a little bit of a unique strategy
and that we focused on the secondary
cities all the cities outside of the m25
there's roughly 100 of those cities
those hundred cities make up 40% of all
the homes 60% of the business population
and is owned 40% of the UK GDP and the
fifth largest economy in the world and
there's no super high quality digital
infrastructure and if you want to
compete on your own around this world
brexit is a good example then you better
have the finest digital infrastructure
you can because you're going alone and a
service based economy let's realize
United Kingdom's a service based economy
service based economies run on the
Internet and the internet runs on fibre
so we need to get fibre into every
premise home and business as fast as we
can and our strategy has been to go
across those secondary cities so over
the last rough seven years we've done a
little bit of an interesting strategy we
use public sector procurements is a way
where we can build the core
infrastructure in those cities and we
don't really concentrate on fibre cable
we concentrate on duct infrastructure I
want hundreds of kilometers of duct
infrastructure in each city because then
I'll subduct at four or five ways and
we'll run fibre cables in there so we
can actually connect every single person
in that in that city so we've done five
duct and infrastructure acquisitions
we've done
9 metro call metro builds were across 42
cities today they're not little cities
so we have a hundred and fifty
kilometers in Edinboro we have enough
subduct and duct capacity to connect
every single home and business and cell
site and traffic light and small cell in
that city so what we're concentrating is
building a core infrastructure in those
cities that can is capable of powering
those cities for the next hundred years
and we believe whatever success we have
will make the whole industry better and
will make UK better and will make
TalkTalk better it'll make sky better
it'll make BT better so we believe in
competition at its roots and we believe
that we're the change Aidid of that
we've raised over five hundred million
pounds that's hard from a company from a
start-up I did it as a pound acquisition
seven years ago I have been building
infrastructure in Europe for going on
almost 25 years in four different
countries so this isn't new but it's
hard to raise capital and put it into
models every single project we do comes
with a contract back its contract back
throws off yield and we are what we like
to think of ourselves as a yield
generating machine now we've we're have
a goal and we've we'll just touch on
that a minute because we want to get
across 20% of the UK we believe that if
we exist and we can demonstrate what we
are saying we can do which is build
faster quicker leaner meaner than
anybody else in the UK it will result in
a lower
hotel price than anybody can offer it
will drive the whole industry to move
faster quicker leaner and cheaper it
will bring prices down from open reach
it'll bring prices down for everybody
and the ultimate consumer will end up
getting what we demonstrated in York
gigabit speeds 425 pounds a month
because we believe that's where the
future is now we use a concept called
the well-planned city design so every
time we go into a city we look at
reorganizing that duct infrastructure
that subduct infrastructure because it's
all about ducts to us underground civil
engineering and to be to be real honest
I would I would I would like city fiber
to be 300 all engineers because I'm an
engineer at heart I'm an engineer I
graduate and we definitely need half of
them to be women so that is our that is
our drive now just looking at our model
real quick we do not do it for homes we
do not do it for mobile we do not do it
for business we do not do it for public
sector we do it for the city and we do
it for all the consumers across that
city so our initial Metrolink or
contract comes in we build that
infrastructure but we design it so that
all business parks all business central
districts get served we design it so we
know where all the macro sites are so
all the macro sites from all the base
stations from all the mobile operators
we map them out we put them on there and
then we design it and route it so that
we can drop cabinets off for fibre to
the home at any time we want and that
was what we did with that trial in New
York as we we showed that you can take
and leverage a poor infrastructure of
design right you can leverage it right
into a reduced cost per home which
results in a wholesale rate that's equal
roughly to the fibre to the cabinet rate
that's the beauty we can actually sell
fiber lines to add a hotel level equal
to the fiber to the cabinet pricing that
BT hotel does or our open reached us now
we just executed a real strategic
contract for us
some people said cheese Greg to us
taking you a while it was like six
months of negotiation I said no seven
years
Doka seven years could add to prove our
model had it proved our economics had to
prove that we could do it had to prove
that we were a supplier what it is
though is the it's a it's an ability to
that can scale across roughly 50 cities
20% of the UK no less than 12 cities in
a million homes so we're on that now and
when we say we're deploying and building
a city we're building the entire city
we're not cherry-picking we're not doing
little sections Milton Keynes was
announced its 80,000 premises will all
get fiber it's 40 million pounds it's
committed construction company moving
and we'll do that through a whole series
of announcements this year that delivers
roughly 50% of the government's full
fiber target
and we're committed to an open access
model so all of our services are open to
BT retail sky talk talk anybody that
wants to use them we have given a little
bit of a period of exclusivity to
Vodafone but we did that in exchange for
them anchoring committing to a minimum
volume commitment of 20% for over 20
years which the formula was what we were
proving was that will anchor in
infrastructure capital at low interest
rates so that's what we're working on
now so we're in that position where I
think we're in a leading position to
keep driving that and to prove those
economics and we're doing it at a city
by city by city basis we also think that
the only way to really get those socio
economics and creativity and innovation
is having the whole city provide not a
little pocket over here of a new home
building or a little pocket over there
where nobody understands where it is but
have the whole city available with
gigabit speeds a fraction of the cost
now obviously if this is the chart
everybody hates to look at but realizes
we need to put fiber into every single
building in my view fiber should be in
every single building home or business
should be in every cell site every small
site that is obvious the next hundred
years we're the the the quality of our
digital infrastructure is directly going
to affect our quality of life and our
productivity and businesses and we just
need to get on and do it now what our
vision really is is that we believe that
the best answer for this is not the
incumbent infrastructures it's just not
they have a role to play but it's not
theirs to own the legacy assets and
their legacy systems get in the way they
don't accelerate them the concept that I
have a whole bunch of junk in the ground
and that I can make it go faster is
completely fallacy we don't touch
anything when we put a new network in
it's all fresh bill we don't worry about
plugging into old systems we don't worry
about knocking off some old copper we
don't worry about displacing revenues
from all of that so we think it's it's
really incumbent upon I used I've heard
incumbent upon actually the governments
and the regulators to look at I have to
have a change agent
have to have somebody in my country that
demonstrates true economics speed and
efficiency because that's what'll drive
my accumbens
on his other 80% of the country so we
feel strongly about having a change
agent like ourselves and each country
we're not depending on in any
incremental revenues obviously we are
taking no revenues and we're taking the
revenue base that is already there and
shifting it off that's hence why I don't
need incremental revenues I need the
same revenues that actually you're
paying today to an open reach for their
hotel prices so proven whole model
builds I think is the answer we believe
we can do it faster we did it fast or
twice we can do it faster quicker and
and the benefits are that it's the lower
cost of consumers so we really believe
in the change and if you don't believe
that somebody fresh can disrupt an old
old environment then must we must not
have just watch four times the larger
payload than anybody's ever lifted at
20% of the cost and NASA said for five
years it couldn't be done
that's what city 5 reviews itself about
we think we can do it twice as quick at
half the price and we can do it for at
least 20% of the UK so
[Applause]
thank you very much Greg thank you to
all of you for who's very interesting
opening remarks I do have some follow-up
questions and I would like to address
first Shawn as the first speaker Shawn
you you have described to us Cyro as
basically a joint venture between a
utility a state-owned utility and
Vodafone
I wonder why utility a state-owned that
is entering the broadband business in
Ireland where there is already a
somewhat established booming market not
a fiber market well I suppose I mean if
the utility obviously the similarities
are fairly plain in terms of it is a
ultimately a wires business electrical
utility and they do have the legacy
network of the electrical network today
with a connection into every home so the
ability to leverage off that is key and
you will find actually that most
electrical utilities have a fair degree
of fiber experience telecoms experience
whether that whether in the case of VSP
they had rolled out some fiber on the
transmission system you know to provide
some backbone backhaul services into the
country already or they typically use it
for their own control sort of in safety
and systems so there's a lot of fiber
crossover into electric electrical
utilities anyway but in terms of the
Irish situation as I think I alluded to
was that you know the utility looked and
said well where can we invest and you
know they did look at Irish water and
all the other opportunities as well but
the broadband sector was one that was
crying out for investment at the time
and I said they've been you know
significant owner investment for over a
decade and the broadband speeds in
regional Ireland and it's not only like
Greg said there if you look outside the
major cities the regional towns even
though the scale of them is different it
had been particularly poorly served so
the opportunity was there and there was
a lot of trials don't buy them to say
could it be done
easily first thing can be done safely
can be done feasibly putting it off on
an electrical system that wasn't
designed for a fiber connection and once
that work was done then you know rolling
with the commercials and then seeking a
partner to do it so I think ultimately
and from an ESP point of view in the
irish case it was can it be done can we
leverage off our existing assets make a
commercial return bringing it abroad in
a partner to bring in some global
innovative sort of you know
technological expertise in the telecom
sector and then just sort of being an
out but there was also the underlying
piece very much at the heart of what
sort of the the utility felt which had
previously don't lure electrification
which was sort of the last big
infrastructure rollout in ireland was
that there was a piece here that they
were delivering for ireland inc that
there was a need at a social level as
well and that drove not just the pure
commercial exploitation of and
leveraging off their existing assets
thank you Elisabetta open fiber has
similarities actually with width IRA you
also have a utility parent you are also
a wholesale only operator I would like
to ask you about wholesale only business
model the business model of choice I
wonder whether you you see it as sort of
a democratic business model in the sense
that you're open to cater for anybody
who wishes to use your network but also
if you could elaborate on the element of
covering not only cities but quite
deliberately also covering rural areas
so that you don't leave anybody behind
yeah you're right we have a few
similarity with with them even if we do
not have an operator in our Sheridan
structure it means that we are wholesale
only and we are open to all potential
customers starting from Vodafone that by
the way is one one of our customers but
all the others player as I mentioned
for and we are very very interesting in
enabling also operators or players that
are not traditionally telco operator
because this is the way we have to
enlarge the offer and the option for the
market but we also look at the
opportunity coming from the specific
situation of the country
I mean Italy for the ones that I've
visited as clear is a country where
average is not exactly the right way to
understanding population distribution of
the population because we are the
country where basically the one-third of
population lives in small cities leaves
in the neighborhood of large cities and
in those areas we add and we have still
but we are working on that a digital
divide so our intention is not to be a
no profit organization for sure we are
not going to look for areas where the
return on investments is not assured but
we think that there is the opportunity
of offering fiber to the areas where due
to the fact that the incumbent has
different priorities there is a
significant digital divide so when I
look at the numbers and I consider that
penetration of broadband is in the
region of seventy five percent at
national level and I divided into
different areas I realized that we are
in the region of eighty five percent in
large cities so we are at the level of
the European bench but we are at in the
region of 50 percent of penetration in
certain areas so we think that there
there we have an opportunity because we
can go with our solution and we can be
the first and being the first mover in
broadband is really the key success
factor considering that when you de
ever fiber and FTTH churning it's very
low so for us it's a great opportunity
on top of that we receive also as I
mentioned the support of our government
in the framework of the Digital Agenda
so we can share the burden of these
investments and this results in a very
let me say win-win a business case not
only for the country but also for us and
our shareholders thank you
turning to move actually you're you're
you're doing the opposite almost as open
reach so open reach has deepened at
separation and now Telia is after 10
years of separation is reintegrating
it's not work infrastructure into the
vertically integrated business could you
please share with us some insights on
what is really the rationale behind the
reintegration and going exactly the
opposite way as some of the other
operators well I think the main reason
is that we need to improve our internal
efficiency and we saw that when we did a
lot of MAS and different companies
definite structure that the other way we
have to do something about it in is we
need to actually take away a lot of
time-consuming discussions internally
the trick is to do that at the same time
keep the wholesale customers that are
operators happy and but we have changed
the market situation as we lost ten
years before we had a lot of conflicts
as I said now we have business relations
with other operators and now have a good
discussions with them and we are eager
to have them as customers because they
are helping us to invest in network and
if you're building an expensive network
with a lot of Catholics of course we
need to have all the customers in that
network it doesn't matter what kind of
source prior issues so we need to take
all the traffic all the revenues into
our network so if we can really prove in
inaction now that we are actually doing
that and other operators are happy and
the regulator has no opinion
so as long as we behave on the market so
I think for us it's like a normal next
step so we have left behind the years of
conflicts in Sweden still we have some
arguments but more like business
arguments so I think we only good
journey this is I find this really quite
fascinating and also kind of turning
next to to Mike mike has mentioned in
his opening statement that we are
creatures of regulation so I wonder
whether you might wish to elaborate on
really how do you see the role of
regulation and how should the role of
regulation play out in defining or
shaping business modernist and also
certainly the EU has a given regulatory
framework which is shifting but not
entirely changing so how would you see
this work out let's say over the next 10
to 20 years what type of business models
and industry structure would you foresee
if you had a crystal ball here ok it's
an excellent question
the I think what's been very interesting
to listen to the panel people here is
there's no one solution right I mean
it's fascinating to hear the different
different implementations in different
countries and territories and so forth
from a UK point of view I think the the
the die has been cast and that is that
you know the the market model that has
been I think encouraged by public policy
regulatory policy has been one of
competition that model typically then
leads you to you know what I call what
in the jargon is called ex-post
regulation in other words that you allow
competition to to to flourish and then
you monitor that from a performance
behavioral point of view and to the
extent you then find market failure or
things of that nature you intervene at
that point after the fact basically that
has led to some great outcomes but it
you know like any model it has its pros
and cons and the big balance I think
that we are now approaching is you you
you can use the model to influence
things like level of competition a
number of parties the competitiveness of
the products and stuff like that but on
the other hand you can also have a
chilling effect on investment or not
depending upon you know how you how you
sort of turn that tap so you know that
that's that's just the model that we
have in the UK if you look at some of
the other utilities you have what's
called the market plan you know ex-ante
model right where basically you you
appoint regional designated providers
the water be electricity or whatever
summer national summit regional there
are lots of different models but the
objective being that you sit down with
that provider you make a plan you agree
their investments you create incentives
for them to make or not make those you
know those investments and you you kind
of socialize the costs of the haves and
have you know of serving haves and
have-nots by effectively having regional
or national pricing or whether that kind
of model can actually has a role in
accelerating you know the deployment of
next generation networks like FTTP in
the UK I'm not sure I'm not sure where
that ship was totally sailed but given
the level of investment that everybody
has to make in the UK over the coming
period it might be worth having a little
Fink as to whether that you know whether
there's any merit in that model but
right now we're charging down the you
know the 20 or 30 year public policy
model of competition thank you looking
at your competitor and the UK market
competitor Greg obviously you you do not
have a legacy fibre network so really
how do you see the fibre investment case
and business case to differ for you as a
new player compared to an operator that
owns a legacy copper network and also
how do you see the role
of copper switch-off and the equation oh
well I think you men I don't have a lazy
copper Network we do we are a pure fiber
network so I think it's an advantage for
us I think the copper incumbents the
copper incumbents are stuck but between
legacy systems legacy assets I mean we
have 300 people we build whole cities
I've built a whole city out of built
14,000 homes we have fall traits that
are 1/100 of a copper net Network it's
it's it's proven it's it's just more
efficient it's easier it's faster it's
quicker it's better so we're with the
man that is the beauty I mean I - all
due respect and I have great respect for
what BT and BT Openreach have done for
the UK but they've created an
environment where it's flourishing
retail competition but not
infrastructure competition there's one
and a half infrastructures across the UK
there's virgin across 50% and open reach
across everything so so you need an
infrastructure competition not having
the legacy copper makes this really fast
and quick and cheap and it and it works
it runs and and we proved it again and
again and again and again and we'll
continue to prove it the beauty of it is
is that we're a yield machine we have
never built any any any fiber networks
on risk every one of our fiber networks
that we build throws off a yield our
target yield is almost 20%
we don't do projects that don't throw
off yields of 10 the reason that the
energy companies and utility companies
are jumping into the fibre space is we
throw off better yields than the
regulated utility space and we throw off
tremendous yields now the copper
switchover is a fantastic thing we're
putting 40 million pounds into Milton
Keynes right now doing 80,000 per
premises if there's a copper switchover
I'd like to switch over all that copper
on all those revenues on to my fiber
network and all twelve cities that we're
building right now and we're putting
half a billion pounds of commitment to
them I'd like all that revenue that's in
there also to be switched over to my
network so as long as the copper
switchover is fair then let's switch it
all off but let's don't switch it off
just for the benefit of one let's
which it off for the benefit of all so I
just don't see it happening I think
that's the problem with the incumbent
right now
and I don't think it's going away and
here's the problem he's going to run two
networks for a long time hence he needs
an incremental return on that investment
hence the price for the consumer is
twice what we can deliver it for and
that's just not going away pure
economics are proving the reason
Vodafone signed to deal with us they
made it very clear two reasons one I
can't conceive of the situation where
the UK goes back to a monopoly provider
for fiber so I need to help to City
fibers offering me fiber lines at half
the price of BT open H if that model
works the UK is better off all the way
around because everybody else will have
to respond be more efficient we don't
need 3,000 new workers God's sake that's
the last thing I want so I think the
whole copper switchover is a perfect
perfect perfect analogy it's not gonna
happen and if it happens it should
happen to each of us equally thank you
very much which I think kind of
demonstrates that however boring the
copper switch official and the managing
process of the migration might sound
this is a real crucial element I think
in actually making fibre successfully
happen all across Europe for the benefit
of everyone and I think it is perhaps
worth having more discussion on this
intrinsically kind of boring sounding
topic because it has just such a great
importance
we are almost entirely out of time for
this session so I wonder there is
perhaps one question from the audience
that one of our panelists could respond
to any questions from anybody we see one
question there so we will just say that
one question
I'd actually just be really interested
to hear what Mike I'm sorry sorry could
you please introduce yourself and sort
your affiliation this one I'm Adrienne
Wooster I work for gig Utley in the UK
I'd be really interested to hear
Mike's response to Gregg's copper
switch-off comments actually just to see
whether we can come to an accommodation
on a an even-handed switch off I'd
actually don't own those customers that
decision will be a decision for sky talk
talk and all the other cps that we work
with my job is to give them products and
services at a wholesale level that they
want to continue to consume and I will
work very hard for them to stay on my
wholesale network but ultimately it will
be for my communication providing
customers to make that decision okay
thank you very much thank you very much
to all of our wonderful panelists for
this huge lynches singh discussion
[Applause]